you know a huge part of Chris Pratt's
life is of course his family our Rachel
Smith chatted exclusively with the proud
papa who turns 44 this month about all
the big Milestones he's got coming up
first up you've got your fourth wedding
anniversary how are you and Catherine
celebrating we are going to take a
little time away it's been pretty heavy
duty with a one-year-old and a
three-year-old and a ten-year-old half
the time so we're knee-deeping kids what
do you think the fam is going to pull
off for you for Father's Day I'm gonna
go to the ranch we've got some uh
Shetland Lambs being born and it's a
good it's fishing season being out in
nature for me is is ideal I miss you
Guardians of the Galaxy of course that
trilogy has wrapped up so what do you
hope star-lord's Journey will be it
would have to be pretty special I don't
think I'd want to do it just just
because people would see it you know I
think if the story's not right then it's
best left alone when it comes to Mario
Mario's now surpassed Frozen the box
office wow so when are we gonna get a
safe
I think I think soon
from Mario Kart to a vintage Alfa Romeo
Chris looked oh so Dapper pulling up to
the grand opening of the Panerai
Boutique in New York City you were like
actually an action star you're exactly
like one exactly like one yeah
when did your affinity for watches first
begin I started collecting watches with
actually a Panerai I wore it and I
remember I got complimented by my
co-star Aziz Ansari and I wear them
frequently on a lot of red carpets and
stuff like that we'd like to play a
little game with you called tell me
about the time you ah you like that
little play on words what about the time
you okay so tell me about me about time
you got your first big break I was in
Hawaii I was waiting tables I was pretty
much homeless living in a van and a
wonderful director came into the
restaurant and I waited on her and she
offered me an audition I got the part
and moved to LA within four days tell me
about the time you had a major parenting
fail probably showing my son Jaws too
early and E.T Audrey
finally I want to tell you about the
time that E.T met you for the very first
time oh wow I've seen this
I'm just like I kind of want to punch
that kid I don't know what it is